well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages of tomorrow's newspapers
in the next half hour we'll see what's
making the headlines with steve richards
columnist and broadcaster
and sal mashar broadcaster and former
government special adviser
great to see you both hello to you as
ever though we will turn our attention
to the front pages first of all the
guardian
going with new data about the
effectiveness of the oxford
astrazeneca covert 19 vaccine which
challenges
some of the skepticism in other
countries about using it
the eye reporting that a single shot of
either of the vaccines
currently available here cuts the risk
of serious illness
by 80 percent there we go vaccines cut
the risk of serious illness
it is the same story for the daily
express
one jab brings dramatic drop in hospital
cases their headline
while the telegraph says that fewer than
10 covid patients
over 80 are going to intensive care each
day now
the metro reports on renewed fears for
the health of the duke of edinburgh
after he was transferred to another
hospital for specialist heart care
and prayers for philip is the headline
in the daily mirror
as it reports that the royal mood has
shifted
over the duke's health the daily mail
claims an exclusive with news of what's
described as boris johnson's secret fund
to pay for a costly makeover of number
10 downey street by his fiancee carrie
simons
the star reports that the footballer
cristiano ronaldo
is banned from doing any chores by his
partner in case he injures himself
while the financial times leads with the
chancellor's budget plans to help the
city of london
compete with its foreign rivals
so steve richards selma shah are here
that's where we start salma isn't it the
financial times
looking ahead to the budget and what's
the take then for the ft
well the ft is quite interesting because
it's been talking about
um how it's going to have this
competitive new listing regime
for this these companies that are going
to come in and
be incredibly innovative in terms of the
technology
um now that is a good classic ft
story um but it doesn't really tell you
about the
oh apologies salma you've momentarily
frozen
still frozen steve take up the story if
you oh no there she is you're back again
salma carry on if you can
yes no i think we might redial that one
uh apologies steve let's let's move to
you then um i think sam was about to say
it doesn't say something about something
oh no she's back again salma hello no
don't oh no she's completely gone i'm
sorry steve
um yes yeah carry on steve tell us a bit
more about the ft story
well it highlights one of the many
challenges rishi
sunak is having to face in this budget
context which is quite extraordinary the
pandemic and brexit
and that the ft is one of the few papers
that continues to focus on the
consequences of the brexit deal
negotiated finally
on christmas eve of last year and of
course one of the consequences is that
it was a deal
for goods rather than services and
financial services is a big
part of the british economy so rishi
sunat will be looking at ways
of boosting the city of london and the
financial sector
in that context given the fact that
amsterdam
and frankfurt and others are saying
right okay
you didn't prioritize this sector we're
going to move in
and take some of the uh
some of that a sector away from you so
that's part of
what you'll be doing in the budget it
won't be the main part but you can see
why a paper like the ft
focuses on it indeed so and all of that
is about generating
income which as we all know the city
does contribute to because
rock and hard place springs to mind does
it not um huge overspent by the treasury
as you might expect during a pandemic
but not the time to raise income is that
is that the is that the theory let's
move on to the telegraph shall we
um which is william hague telling the
choice to prepare for tax rises
it's the it's not if but when moment
isn't it but it is the general feeling
that
now is not the time well it depends who
you
speak to there is a powerful argument
for saying
that this is still the equivalent of a
wartime situation
and in such a context you don't raise
taxes i think we're going to come on to
the labor position
shortly but what's interesting about the
hague piece telling tories to prepare
for tax rises
is that it's very difficult these days
for a tory chancellor
to win parliamentary approval in his own
or her own party
for tax rises philip hammond put forward
a tax rise
this was of course pre-pandemic in the
ancient history period
it was defeated or it was clear that it
was going to be defeated
some of george osborne's proposed tax
rises
uh were defeated by revolts
and there is uh an indication anyway
that there is a degree
of opposition within the current
parliamentary party now with a much
bigger
majority to tax rises in this budget
there's a curious alliance with the
labour leadership
that also believes for different reasons
now is not the time for tax rises
but clearly uh rishi sunak and others
given the briefings that have come
to the sunday papers and others are
preparing
for tax rises whether they will be
implemented immediately
or uh preparation is laid out
for tax rises in the months to come we
will have to wait
for wednesday but tax rises will be
part of sunac's chosen route through
the economic timetable out of the
pandemic
and this will be an interesting test for
a tory parliamentary party
that has quite often shown itself to be
deeply skeptical
about tax rises almost as a matter of
principle yes it's interesting isn't it
because many of the papers are still
focusing on the giveaway
elements of what the budget will hold
the sun earlier talking about
fuel duty will be frozen again the
telegraph talking here about the
chancellor wanting to
help 130 000 small businesses
including a help to grow scheme which
would be 5 000 pounds for businesses to
buy new software for example
to improve their online operations so
there's still a giveaway element of it
so we're still spending money
and which takes us to the guardian and
and this strange position where
labour is backing a rise in business tax
eventually but not now
salmon what have they said
um so i think this is really part of the
labour
move to try and uh become the party of
business again and reassure people
that the jeremy corbyn period is over
and annelise dods has certainly talked
about
exactly as you say as the guardian is
reporting that
they are now looking at tax rises
longer in the future because they feel
that this is a risky time for the
economy
um and don't want to do anything
especially post-pandemic
um to for the
for the economy recovery
i think yeah carry on i was gonna say
what i think is really interesting about
this
um is that actually the last election
2019 in
post-brexit has completely changed the
electoral map and what we're now seeing
um is the political consequence of that
where you're actually
uh being conservative mps um
asking for a bigger state which as i
think i just heard steve talking about
is pretty unprecedented
and the and the labour party sort of
thinking about how it's going to push
its market credentials so this is going
to be a really interesting budget from a
political perspective definitely
and this was always the question wasn't
it after election night
you know did those parts of the north
lend the tourists their vote for one
specific point
and can the tourists keep hold of them
so they've always got that in the back
of their mind haven't they
um which takes us to the the star in
sheffield
leveling up has achieved nothing so far
and this is
an mp suggesting the big north-south
differences remain unchanged and
long-term efforts are needed
um once again is that something that
rishi-sunak will have an eye on
yeah absolutely i think rishi is going
to have an eye on the
leveling up agenda but mostly because it
actually hasn't been defined by any
particular policy
so there is a golden opportunity here in
the budget
for him to be able to define what
leveling up actually means
but as you can see from the sheffield
star and i think there's also
um the yorkshire post there um there is
a
massive amount of skepticism
particularly not just from the the
labour mps in and around the area but
also um from the media outlets and civic
groups because
there is a sense that we've heard this
all before and you know the leveling up
agenda
it's precursor with things like the
northern powerhouse under george osborne
so you know it is going to require some
money and it doesn't feel like
um there is something significant coming
in the budget towards that particularly
and just um a final thought back to the
daily telegraph in fact william hague
suggesting that
uh conservatives need to prepare
themselves for
for tax increases both personal and
business
what should we be expecting ultimately
do you think what will the tories go for
more income tax corporation taxes
obviously been mooted quite a lot as
well
where would you level up these level
these taxes out then
oh i think we might musama as well i
think corporation
do you know i blame the meteor to be
fair
we're going to take a break we've got so
much to pack in in the next half of our
program we'll get the very latest on
uh covid the vaccines and the variants
and also the latest two
on those renewed fears for the health of
the duke of edinburgh on the front page
of the metro and elsewhere back in just
a moment
our job is to tell the truth this is a
forgotten front line
they are dying here
boy we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us
get ready instructing you to stay at
home
i can't believe we did that it's pretty
special isn't it
you learn you learn quickly in china
football that um
nothing can come as a surprise anymore
but um
what has happened this has nothing to do
with football so
in china football is not grassroots or
bottom-up like it's normally is in
europe it's
it's a top-down affair so
big corporations like sooning which is
one of the biggest companies in china
they operate these clubs sort of at the
you know
goodwill of the government of the local
government
and what's happened is that the
corporation has run into that repayment
problems
and they have to get rid of
you know what they don't consider as
core business which uh football
isn't it's sort of like a mix of
walmart amazon
paypal you know the they have a cell
phone operator so it's a it's a huge
company
that is now running it into problems
that has nothing to do with football and
this is what
what they've come up with so i've
actually heard from a couple players
both side and you know it's come
obviously as a shock
so you know most of them will be looking
for new clubs
um but what will probably happen is that
um
like normally in china somebody else
will take over the operations
but um it's the same with suning because
they've
invested a lot in the in in football in
jiangsu and and jiangsu is actually a
traditional chinese football powerhouse
so they've actually run a you know a
pretty impressive ship
it was very professional to work for
them and a lot of you know professional
people who were
running the organization so they had a
huge youth program they had a one of the
you know best funded women's teams in
the world when
i was over there and they've actually
won the title in 2019
so um somebody else will take over but
you know it
remains to be seen if they can continue
at the same level of operations
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now summer shot
and hopefully back soon steve richards
we're having one of those nights aren't
we uh welcome to the world of zoom and
every other means of of modern
communication that we all know and love
over the last year salma
and let's move on to kovid shall we and
the
really heartening news we had from the
downey street news conference
about the efficacy of these vaccines
which all of us were desperate to hear
yeah it's absolutely incredible so
you've got um fewer than 10 coveted
patients
now going into icu which is i think
even better than had been expected in
terms of the efficacy of the astrazeneca
vaccine so we are really seeing light at
the end of the tunnel
but there are two things that i think
are slightly difficult here
uh which are number one um that we have
to keep an eye on the mutations
and you know as we come out of lockdown
um
mutations as people start moving around
are going to become
more likely and obviously there is still
this particular case of a brazilian
mutation that
the government is trying to track down
and then also
there is the eu um dimension to it where
you know previously we saw president
macron and german officials
sort of doubting uh the uh the ability
of this particular vaccine
and i think now matt hancock is urging
um uh governments to start taking up the
vaccine
i think partly because it's about making
sure that our european neighbours
are secure in terms of their vaccine
programs
but also perhaps a little bit of a
i told you so as well from the uk
government absolutely and also if you're
in discussions with the european union
for trips abroad in the summer should it
come to that you want the eu to take up
the vaccine and it's been quite pitiful
hasn't it in parts of
france and germany for example i see the
french health minister
uh tonight has said that over 65s can
take it
but only up to the age of 74 and after
that
if you're older than that you still need
to take the fisa or moderna vaccines
welcome back steve it's one of those
nights it's it's a one isn't it
uh we're talking about the vaccination
success the eye as well
vaccines cut the risk of serious illness
by 80 percent
um and just reflecting on the fact that
possibly other parts of europe may
change their minds on the um efficacy of
the extra
astrazeneca jab for older people
i think that's inevitable um all the
evidence suggests that the
astrazeneca vaccine is effective and is
crucially effective
on older people so all that original
feverish panic stricken furore about
whether
that would be the case uh in parts of uh
uh is just challenged by the evidence so
i think we are going to move past that
phase quite quickly
what's so interesting is this is of
course for
unqualified optimism i think and it will
spread beyond the uk
well beyond the uk but of course at the
same time
as ever with this saga there's uh
underlying causes for concern such as
the new variant and that too is in the
papers tomorrow so you
get as has been often the case over the
last week or so
stories which make you say yeah we're
getting through this
and then just the hints of concern and
worry
about variants how they get here in the
uk
and what they imply by getting here
yes and you know other worries like what
happens post 35 days for the
fisa vaccine for example given it's not
being given
as protocol dictated by the creators at
biontech guardian 2 hancock seizes on
data to urge the eu to think again on
the oxford jab so similar theme there
um let's just go uh sombra with a final
thought
on uh what's happening with the duke of
edinburgh
making a number of the front pages as
well not least the metro philip
hart fears and obviously everybody
wishing him well as he moves hospitals
today
yes indeed wishing him well um but also
obviously with a degree of concern
um because obviously palace protocol
dictates that sort of personal health
um details aren't uh really released
so all you really get are um notes to
tell you that
selma honestly i think you've gone again
i apologize we're running out of time
but
we're going to make it all lovely and
brilliant for 11 30 when we see you back
again
uh salma and steve thank you both very
much indeed